oh hi there and good morning I was just
working on the happy dance project Hank
I'm in New York City and I'm not gonna
lie to you I've had a long day there's
been a lot of eating and drinking and
just general merriment I have the oddest
sensation that I'm being looked at well
hello there sweet scarlet look hey it's
morning Johnson's new book sweet scarlet
except instead of being in book form its
in gigantic poster form anyway Hank
there was a lot of eating and drinking
and I'm feeling really overstuffed but
you know in life you have to have moral
principles which guide you and one of my
moral principles has always been that
when people want to buy me stuff I want
to let them I believe that's what they
call the Christmas spirit Hank I'm in
New York meeting with people about Paper
Towns and one of those people is of
course my brilliant editor Julie Strauss
Gable hello Hank
check it out Hank Julie has a view of
the Statue of Liberty from her office
and at the end of the day you know what
Julie did Hank she sent you a copy of
Paper Towns I hope you like it
and Hank guess who's here that's right
it's Maureen Johnson hi Hank let me ask
you a serious question Maureen as as one
of the most popular authors for
teenagers in America who do you like
more me or Hank Hank it's funny because
it's true hey Hank what can I say the
teen authors of America love you but as
I always remind myself it's not a
competition because if it were a
competition I'd lose by the way Hank do
you know that Maureen Johnson went to my
pants it's still funny it's funny after
eight months it's still funny but anyway
Maureen started to thread in my pants
called if you had John Green on your
couch for a night what would you do the
answers frankly disturbing except for
secret brother Tom who proposed putting
a ferret inside my pillowcase by the way
Hank I want to thank all the
nerdfighters for helping me pick out
names from my hypothetical puppy my
favorites included random Valona
Chomsky the nerdfighting puppy woot
poner Optimus Prime and Johnny fun times
but Hank the doubtless winner has to be
Norbert Wiener the puppy Hank with
name like Norbert Wiener my hypothetical
puppy will be the nerd fight earliest
hypothetical puppy of them all stop
looking at me
Hank since the rebirth of question
Tuesday's went so well I've decided I'm
going to do it again so nerdfighters if
you have any questions you'd like me to
answer in my Tuesday video leave them
down there Hank have fun reading Paper
Towns and I'll see you on Monday